quite easy to demonstrate there is a
fairly substantial gap to men and women
in fact some over the last 40 years the
difference in rating between men even
has barely changed at all and it's it's
quite significant it would mean that a
player who is let's say ranked number 50
in the world a male ranked number 50 in
the worlds as opposed to the top ticking
woman the male would probably win are in
excess of 70 75 percent of school 75
percent I'm just wondering whether that
serious science or whether that's to do
with sexism because some chests I seem
to have a real problem with sexist
attitudes and Sabrina's Shiva knows the
British women's international master
says she's faced it all her career
sexist jokes put-down she was asked if
he want she wanted to play in the junior
section so the fact that there aren't
very women maybe winning women playing
chess is it to do with the way their
brains are wired or the attitudes they
face when they try and participate um
look I I think probably sexism is is an
issue in chess and I've them try and
escape from that I Sabrina would know
much better she's had personal
experience of that but so there are
plenty of countries or countries like
Georgia where there was very very
substantial female participation it's
roughly 30 percent which is in fact much
higher than in the UK for example
comments' are helping I mean you could
say that your comments are actually
incredibly damaging it's like saying
girls are very good at maths science or
driving I think in fact in this article
you do say that men are better at
driving them women uh you know women
have better verbal skills the women have
all sorts of skills where they are
Superior's member i said things actually
quite fun controversial which an amazing
number of people have criticized they
said you know men and women are
hardwired differently they have friends
of hardwired differently there are
observable observable sex differences in
the brains even in the fetus men have
brains which are ten percent larger they
also have considerably more gray matter
women have very very much more white
matter in their brains than their men
you do when we do have we do have
different brains we do have different
ways of thinking but we can still
achieve the same results we just get
about it different ways I mean you were
beaten by Judith polgár the former
women's world champion did she bring her
man brain that day not a lot of timing
Judy Olga is by far the most successful
um woman player in chess history and
she's a she's a giant of the game and
the fact that I have a bad score against
one individual woman doesn't doesn't
prove anything that the general point so
I'm talking about averages here I'm
delighted that players like older and
all group um who is the great young
Chinese player are able to compete on on
a very high level and I believe women
can attain that they have already done
that but they statistically they don't
do it in the in the same numbers and the
average gap is pretty large and I think
that is down to sex differences I don't
know what those differences are every
person I speak to has a different theory
some people say it's male aggression
I had Sabrina shabam who you quoted are
talking about men being more obsessive
than women it could be true but whatever
the reasons for that skill in chess and
I don't I
made any attempt to define what those
are those sex differences exist exist
and the point of my article was that I
said that I think we should just accept
that okay well I'm gonna admit I can't
play that this has been a real incentive
for me to take up the game and try and
prove me wrong I got a magic show
ranking good when I get good I'll come
back to you we'll have a game